what's it like to be a part of a film
like this and get acknowledged so early
in award season yeah it's I almost it's
tremendously overwhelming I've only been
here 15 minutes but I've already seen
about 30 people I've admired and studied
closely for a number of years now so to
get up there the only to get up there in
front everyone the only thought on my
mind is not to explode or like poop my
pants or something are me here as well
Army's not here and this is that's the
guy who we're all eating in this kind of
situation and you'd be the one that'd be
talking me and you know talking me down
so I lost my brother an armor tonight
but he'll be back what's it like because
that's a really personal experience
playing a character like that what's it
been like for your relationship with
Army III he's become one of my best
friends and he's a mentor and as much as
a paternal figure and as much as a
brother and he's like really one of my
great friends you know we didn't read
together for these roles or for this
relationship for this movie and somehow
there was a random luck of the universe
of something where we genuinely
appreciate each other as human beings or
something
you have a speech worked out yeah yeah I
got a little something yeah I know yeah
cuz I wouldn't trust myself to get up
there I could just manically ramble and
stutter so I'm glad I have something
I'll tell you what a word season is a
long run you ready for it I you know if
if this is already very overwhelming if
this was it it would already be beyond
my wildest dreams